do you think that this is a simulation I
guess I thought of the topic
oh my gosh I don't think this is a
simulation
why don't oh because it it's a good
question
he's I haven't seen like I know there
was like this argument that it is a
simulation here's the the data but I
just feel like you are a numbers man I
am a numbers man and is a possibility I
would not dismiss the possibility
simulation at a hand I would not but and
I also him there are times when when it
does feel like you're walking and like
steps that have been like lay down in
front of you in the sand I mean there's
like sometimes that sense but but I
still believe it's us and we're we're
doing in we're choosing in we're making
happen do you believe in free will you
know yeah I do believe in free will to a
point like I do think it's not that that
many of the virtues that we praise in
people it's like oh that's just like you
know cuz certainly to the extent I'm
capable of of anything like there are a
lot of things that went into it in terms
of my parentage and you know it's like
so so even the things where I think I'm
choosing like they're probably a lot of
things that you know we're just my
wiring or at the fact that you know my
dad like pushed me in a certain way or
whatever yes